they were testing drugs for pigs and
cows on me what uh it was like a medical
study for money I made two grand dude
plus I was living on the streets what
the side effects made your heart rate go
super fast the idea was that pigs and
cows would have less fat meat but
if they're going to do this then
whenever anybody eats the meat the trace
of the drug is going to go into the
human body which means they got to do
tests they had to find out how much the
human body could handle of that 80%
of pork that you eat has that in it
damn so it worked well I I
guess I was telling Isaac about this the
other day he looked up the drug and he
read off the internet very little is
known about it it was only ever tested
on six young healthy males Dam and I'm
like dude I was absolutely one of those
six it was a place called armaco life
science research in Austin Texas and